[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain the american comedy drama
film called the truman show
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
truman burbank leads a quiet and
peaceful life in seahaven island his
birthplace he is married to a nurse
named merrill and works as an insurance
salesman
one day as he is heading to work after
greeting his neighbors across the street
with his traditional greeting in case i
don't see you good afternoon good
evening and good night a strange object
falls from the sky and lands near his
car he tries to ascertain where it came
from but doesn't find any answers as the
sky is clear and the object seems like a
studio light he brushes it aside and
drives to work on his way to work the
radio reports that an aircraft flying
over the seahaven island shed its parts
which makes him believe it was the
source of the object at work he makes a
secret call to fiji and asks for
information about a woman named lauren
slash sylvia garland when he fails to
find any information
he leaves to close a deal on harbor
island for his boss lawrence however his
fear of open water gets to him and he
returns home
later he meets his childhood best friend
marlon and confides in him his wish to
leave everything behind and move to fiji
ever since truman was a child he wished
to explore the world but due to one
thing or another he never got to go
beyond seahaven island after marlin
leaves truman sits by the beach alone
and remembers a boating accident because
of which he lost his father kirk burbank
on that fateful day truman's father
wanted to return from home early due to
the bad weather but truman had insisted
on staying out at sea for a bit longer
lo and behold a strong storm hit their
boat and mr burbank got swept overboard
and drowned as truman snaps out of his
memory a strange thing happens it begins
to rain but only on him he stands up in
astonishment and it begins to rain
everywhere he rushes home and shares his
plans about moving to fiji with merrell
but she dismisses the idea citing their
financial obligations and plans to have
a baby the next day truman runs into a
homeless man on the street who looks
just like his father but before he could
talk to the man a number of people and
obstacles show up and the man is dragged
into a bus and taken away truman shares
the incident with his mother but mrs
burbank dismisses it as truman's
imagination she tells him that she too
sees mr burbank in strangers sometimes
and it is normal
that night truman goes into his basement
and looks through his old personal
belongings hidden away in an old trunk
the trunk contains pictures of his
childhood and a red lady's sweater with
a pin that says how will it end the
sweater takes him back to his college
days when he saw a beautiful young woman
named lauren garland while playing in
the homecoming band with marlon before
he could court her lauren disappeared
and over time truman got romantically
close to merrell however one evening
truman again runs into lauren in the
library he approaches her but she tells
him that she's not allowed to speak with
him despite this truman smitten by her
asks her if she'd go out with him on the
weekends
however she tells him that she can only
go out now and the two try to head out
of the library secretly the cameras in
the library lose them for a second but
eventually capture them running out
together through an alternative exit the
pair make out on the beach but suddenly
a vehicle approaches them causing lauren
to panic she tells truman that her real
name is actually sylvia and tries to
tell him the truth about the truman show
as the man claiming to be mr garland
tries to drag her away lauren tells
truman that everything and everyone
around him is fake and part of a reality
tv show the man calls lauren
schizophrenic and takes her away
announcing that they are moving to fiji
truman watches in confusion with the red
sweater that lauren left behind after he
returns to reality truman pieces
together scraps of magazine pages to
create a collage of sylvia's face as he
remembers it the next day on his way to
work the radio malfunctions and oddly
reports every movement he makes as if he
is being watched soon the radio again
starts playing music after apologizing
for picking up the police's frequency
paranoid truman rushes into a random
building to catch the people conspiring
against him slipping as he heads towards
an elevator he is surprised to see what
seems to be a tv studio filled with
people wearing headphones and eating
lunch instead of an elevator car before
he can wrap his head around what he is
seeing the security arrives and kicks
him out for trespassing confused he
meets marlon and tells him about the
strange occurrences however marlon
dismisses it as his imagination
nevertheless truman confides in marlin
that he is going to go away for a while
when truman returns home he finds his
mother and meryl looking at old photos
of them while on the tv a show called
show me the way to go home is playing it
seems everyone is indirectly trying to
dissuade him from going on an adventure
truman suddenly notices his wedding
picture where meryl has her fingers
crossed implying that meryl didn't marry
him truthfully the next day truman aims
to travel to fiji but learns that there
are no available flights for at least a
month he then catches a bus to chicago
but the bus breaks down before it even
gets to leave the station merrill
returns home from work and finds truman
sitting in his car he invites her to sit
next to him and correctly predicts a
chain of events a lady on a red bike a
man with flowers and a volkswagen beetle
with a dented fender he claims that
everything around him is scripted but
she dismisses him as she attempts to
leave truman locks the car door and
starts driving around spontaneously to
prove his theory he begins to drive out
of the island but the fear of open water
takes over him and he stops on the
bridge which connects seahaven island to
the rest of the country
determined to leave he shuts his eyes
and slams his foot on the accelerator
forcing merrill to drive they
successfully cross the bridge and
continue on their journey but they are
soon forced to stop by police just
before a nuclear power plant that seems
to have had a meltdown a police officer
orders him to retreat but accidentally
calls truman by his first name despite
having never met him before convinced of
foul play truman attempts to run from
the island but the men capture him and
send him back home back at home meryl
tries to convince him that everything is
fine but truman gets even more paranoid
suddenly marlon appears at the door and
takes truman out for a beer marlin
assures him that everyone is not
conspiring against him merlin further
adds if everyone did he would have to be
a co-conspirator too but he could never
lie to his best friend it is then
revealed that a man named kristoff is
feeding these lines to marlin through an
earpiece marlon then reveals the real
reason he brought him over for a beer
and a man then appears from the mist it
is revealed to be the homeless man that
truman was convinced was his father it
turns out he was right it is mr burbank
who marlin found on the island the
father and son embrace as kristoff
instructs his camera crew to beautifully
capture the moment mr burbank tearfully
promises his son to make up for the time
they lost it is finally confirmed that
truman is the star of the most popular
live show in tv history called the
truman show unbeknownst to him truman's
hometown the seahaven island is a
massive tv set surrounded by a dome that
produces sophisticated effects and
imagery to mimic the sky weather and
temperature of the real world the dome
is run by a huge staff under the command
of the eccentric director kristoff in an
interview kristoff reveals kirk burbank
is not the first one to enter the show
without being a part of the script and
there have been several attempts by fans
to meet truman it is also revealed that
kristoff previously killed kirk's
character just to implant the fear of
water in truman so he wouldn't think of
leaving the island truman's birth was a
case of unwanted pregnancy and he was
the first child to be adopted by a
corporation for a tv show the show runs
24 7 and generates revenues by product
placements while taking fan questions
kristoff gets an angry call from sylvia
garland who berates him for imprisoning
truman without his consent kristoff
retorts by saying the real world is the
actual prison while the cell that truman
lives in gives him the chance to lead a
completely normal life free of violence
or pain he finishes by adding that
truman is free to leave should he
discover the truth the next day truman
seems to have gone back to his normal
self at work he is introduced to a new
co-worker named vivian appointed by
kristoff as truman's prospective female
partner later that evening truman falls
asleep in a makeshift bed in his
basement while organizing things after
several hours of inactivity kristoff
grows worried and orders the crew to
ring truman's phone however truman
doesn't answer much less move kristoff
then sends marlon over to his home with
a pack of beer kristoff guides him to
the basement and to everyone's
astonishment it is revealed that truman
is absent from his bed marlin then
discovers a large hole in the basement
leading to the lawn truman has managed
to escape with nothing to show the
audience kristoff cuts the live
transmission for the first time ever in
the history of the show the cease and
the transmission of the iconic show
sends shockwaves around the world
pressure from fans media investors and
sponsors is kicking kristoff's ass he
orders the entire staff including the
extra actors to go on a manhunt however
the actors find it hard to find a man in
the dark so kristoff orders the sun to
rise well before the actual time of
sunrise to aid in the search for truman
after searching every inch of the land
kristoff's intuition tells him to check
the sea surrounding the island it works
and the cameras spot truman on a
sailboat with a picture of sylvia the
live transmission is again resumed at
home sylvia is elated to see truman
trying to find the truth kristoff orders
the fairy captain to fetch truman but
being just an actor he doesn't know how
to man a boat left with no other choice
kristoff simulates a storm to force
truman to go back to port kristoff
leaves no stone unturned to scare truman
but he puts up a fight and defiantly
yells at the sky is that the best you
can do you are gonna have to kill me
enraged kristoff sends c-wave after sea
wave to break truman almost capsizing
the boat and nearly drowning him
kristoff realizes that truman would
rather dive and concede and finally
allows the sky to clear truman continues
to sail away soon his boat is rocked by
a strong impact truman learns that his
boat has collided with the sky wall he
has reached the end of the dome he
breaks into tears of joy walking on the
edge of the sky he reaches a staircase
leading to an exit door as he proceeds
to exit kristoff finally speaks to
truman through the intercom and informs
him that he is the star of a reality tv
show called the truman show he tries to
convince truman to continue to live on
his fantasy island as sylvia and the
entire world watch intently on their tv
sets kristoff tells him there's no more
truth out there in the world than i
created for you the same lies the same
deceit but in my world you have nothing
to fear after some deliberation truman
looks up at the sky and says
in case i don't see you good afternoon
good evening and good night before
bowing and leaving an elated sylvia
rushes out of her apartment in
excitement as the rest of the world
erupts in cheers and happiness at the
finale of the truman show subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching